narendra modi persona non grata au
bangladesh en visite diplomatique
pendant deux jours le premier ministre
indien suscite la colère de certains
habitants
de nombreuses manifestations ont eu lieu
notamment à l'appel du mouvement
islamiste et phase at un groupe
extrémiste qui accuse le leader
nationaliste d'attiser la haine envers
les musulmans
[Applaudissements]
narendra modi est un [ __ ] de sang
partout où il va
le sang coule au gujarat au cachemire
est maintenant à dacca
nous ne voulons pas de cette terreur
dans notre pays quitter immédiatement le
bangladesh et sauver votre honneur
sinon nous vous ferons quitté le pays
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis trois jours les manifestations à
travers le pays dégénère devant la
principale mosquée du pays à dacca des
centaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées une mobilisation qui s'est
étendu à plusieurs villes du bangladesh
doté d'un important réseau d'écoles
islamiques
le groupe et phase at a également appelé
à la grève générale ce dimanche 13
personnes pour la plupart membres du
mouvement radical ont été tués lors
d'affrontements avec les forces de
l'ordre
des dizaines de blessés sont à déplorer
certains étudiants réclament justice
l'horrible incident qui a eu lieu le
jour de l'indépendance n'a jamais été
voulu par nous nous demandons des
actions en justice contre les
responsables
nous demandons des funérailles
nationales et déshonneur pour nos frères
qui sont morts et blessés nous demandons
également une indemnisation pour eux
alors que les forces de l'ordre ont
procédé à de nombreux tirs de grenades
lacrymogènes et de balles en caoutchouc
des garde-frontières ont été déployés
pour aider au maintien de l'ordre
le ministre de l'intérieur a annoncé
qu'il n'hésiterait pas à prendre les
mesures qui s'imposent si la situation
ne s'améliore pas